bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 78
sport une édition un petit peu Express
ce soir on passe tout de suite au titre
en image cette semaine le vélodrome de
50 ans nine a enfin ouvert ses portes
nous avons suivi ses premiers locataires
sur la piste mais pas queux nous
reviendrons sur le choc de football
féminin entré en cours et tremblit pour
le compte de la 9e journée de promotion
d'honneur attention à la valange de but
en perspective la réserve des Templiers
desé lancours en football US joué son
premier match officiel en championnat
régional face au Fox de Chantilly une
première victoire pour lancer cette
saison avec en ligne de mière évidemment
les play-offs et en fin d'émission comme
d'habitude tous les autres résultats du
weekend mais tout d'abord on passe au
cyclisme et au Vélodrome de C
ni ouvert officiellement depuis quelques
jours le vélo ome de 50 an nine
accueille déjà de nombreux cyclistes sur
la piste mais le site permet de
pratiquer d'autres disciplines comme le
badminton ou le selfdfense Jonathan
vilman pour les images c'est leur toute
première prise de contact avec lesécin
de 50 ans en Yveline et même si cette
dizaine de cyclistes sont des pistars
confirmé les exigences de l'anneau du
Vélodrome les obligent à reprendre les
bases c'est toute une façon de pédaler
qui est différente de la route avec un
vélo sans sans frein un pignon fixe on
travaille d'abord une une mise en train
c'est-à-dire une séance de entre 20 et
25 minutes d'échauffement avec leur
apprendre à avoir la la science du train
c'està-dire de pas faire d'accélération
et après on a fait des petits des petits
des petits exercices deapendre à se
mettre en danseuse après une heure passé
sur la selle ces cyclistes ont du mal à
quitter cette piste unique au monde au
début c'est surprenant mais après avec
avec l'habitude on commence à monter
d'ailleurs on a fait un exercice là
plusieurs où on a monté à moitié 3/4 de
la piste mais c'est tout de même
impressionnant j'ai tourné à Manchester
j'ai tourné à roubé et là la première
impression le rendement il est
exceptionnel il y a vraiment un
rendement et je pense que c'est une
piste qui permettra de battre des
records rien que pour la première
journée d'ouverture la piste a accueilli
plus d'une centaine de cyclistes
l'abonnement annuel vous coûtera 250 €.
mais au sein du Vélodrome il n'y a pas
que du cyclisme au milieu de l'air
centrale juste derrière moi se trouvent
des terrains de bminton libre à la
location et dans les través du
Clairfontaine du cyclisme français vous
pourrez découvrir le selfck défense la
salle d'entraînement n'est pas encore
terminé mais les passionnés sont déjà au
rendez-vous ici les élèves apprennent à
se défendre avec des simulations de
situation du quotidien mais aussi touche
au sport de combat comme le kickboxing
ou le penchakila 10 mois de cours de
self kick défense vous coûteront près de
€.
ce weekend le stade guide Boniface
accueillait un match de gala pour la 9e
journée de promotion d'honneur féminine
et l'encs recevait le leader invaincu
tremblé en France et on a eu le droit à
une avalanche de but image d'éod moine
avec la réception du leader
tremblaésiens les Amazones des lancour
avaient de quoi signer un match
référence et surtout lancer leur seconde
partie de saison après 10 minutes un peu
brouillon sandig CALV met au propre
s'est enroulé du droit dans le petit
filet mais réponse du leader ne se fait
pas attendre 2 minutes plus tard la très
remuante Jen Loga déclenche cette frappe
soudaine qui s'écrase sous la barre un
partout et les tremblaisiennes
enchaînent sur cette superbe ouverture
Florine vavran lobe astucieusement
Emelina doudeek trembla mène 21 après un
quart d'heure et la valangeche de but
continue et l'encours répond sur cette
frappe lobé de sandigon calves qui va de
son doublé de après 33 minutes après ça
plus grand chose à griffonner sur la
copie jusqu'à la
mi-temps a tour des vestiaires tremblait
prend à la gorge les Amazones maintenu à
flot par Emelina duddeek hauteur d'un
double arrêt de grande classe sur ce
coup franc mal dégagé par sa
défense ce qui réveille les élans
courtoises Anaïs modui passé aux
avant-postes transmet à Denise moala qui
efface la gardienne mais sa frappe et
repoussé sur la
ligne on se dirige alors vers un match
nul plutôt logique quand Jen Loga encore
elle prend de vitesse la défense et
mystifie la gardienne cinquentinoise
Tremblet s'impose finalement 3 à2 fin de
match cruel
re
leaderisent
deitisb de saisou tout
ça March par
interm
fa de Constance niveau du
je de suite à l'essenti des résultat du
weekend
c'était le weekend de reprise pour pas
mal de championnats toute discipline
confudu ces deux derniers jours en
football 11e journée de promotion
d'honneur Guill en cours n'a pas pesé
bien Lourdin face au leader fleur
Merogis les joueurs de Jud talmoro se
sont inclinés 5 buts à deux et restent
9e de leur poule dans la poule B la
rencontre opposant traape à gargelgonès
a été reporté chez les femmes c'était
aussi la reprise pour la division 2 et
on suit évidemment Montini qui s'est une
nouvelle fois incliné cette fois-ci sur
la pelouse du 2èe vanen 3 buts à 0
toujours lanterne rouge les ÉIS
montaines ont désormais 6 points de
retard sur le premier non relégable le
maintien se complique match après match
en rugby 14e journée de fédéral 3
plaisir continue sur sa cadence
impressionnante les joueurs de Philippe
Béard se sont facilement imposés à mot
sur le score de 30 à 3 en tennis de
table 9e journée de probé l'cs s imposée
à mulouse 4 matchs à un les joueuses de
Franck solniier toujours invaincu
confortent leur place de leader ce
weekend c'était aussi la reprise pour
l'entente de voisin saint-ornou qui
jouait son tout premier match en
National 1 face à saint-pierrez candidat
à l'approbé les joueuses de geoffrein
nzan se sont logiquement inclinés 8
matchs à deux en handball 12e journée de
National 2 la belle série continue pour
Montini les inimontaines se sont imposé
à domicile face à Plouvorn d'un tout
petit but he 26 25 et reste 4e au
classement général toujours du Hand Ball
chez les juniors les moins 18 ans les
moins 18 ans de plaisir justement jouer
leur tout premier match de championnat
de France ce weekend face à potoobo
hauteur d'une excellente entame de match
les joueurs d'Alexandre pifer que vous
voyez sur l'écran mènent rapidement CIN
buts à deux mais face à un club
professionnel et avec plusieurs joueurs
malades les Plaisirois sent peu à peu du
terrain au retour des vestiaires ils
arrivent à rester au contact avec trois
buts de retard mais l'impact physique
adverse va faire la décision dans les
toutes dernières minutes pontoobo
s'impose finalement 35
29 en basket basket féminin tout d'abord
national une 15e journée nouvelle
défaite he pour l'Entente le chîn et
Versailles face à toire cette fois-ci un
concurrent direct pour le maintien les
coéquipières de Virgin rincan réalise
l'entame de match parfaite pour
rapidement mener 197 avant que Toir
recolle à 6 points à la pose 43 à 37 le
3è carton est fatal aux joueus de
Stéphane Rollet imp puissante devant la
réussite adverse à 3 points le LCV
s'incline finalement 80 à 72 et reste
11e de sa poule le le maintien là aussi
se complique de plus en plus chez les
hommes en National 3 après sa victoire
dans le derby Vinois face à trappe
l'entente le chîn et Versailles s'est
incliné sur le parquet du ministère des
Finances 83 à 71 après quatre défaites
consécutives trappe de son côté a
retrouvé la victoire à domicile face à
malakov succès 72 à 61 les deux clubs
ilinois conserve respectivement leur 8e
et 9e place en football américain la
saison 2014 14 du championnat régional
d'île-de-fance reprenait ses droits ce
weekend pour cette première journée la
réserve des Templiers recevait au
complex sportif d'élancour les Fox de
chantill les joueurs de gillramat
démarrent idéalement la rencontre avec
un premier touch Jun dès les toutes
premières minutes et il s'impose
facilement dans ce premier match de la
saison 27 à 6 de quoi lancer évidemment
idéalement cette saison en championnat
régional où les Templiers sont très
ambitieux je vous propose d'écouter
l'entraîneur au micro d'éodim on a 3
mois et demi c'est un peu long mais bon
en même temps on a pas mal de nouveaux
intégrés à chaque fois et c'est pas
toujours facile de les intégrer
directement l'objectif c'est d'aller en
play-off puis une fois en play-off bah
essayer de gagner de voir si on peut pas
monter en D3 c'est une équipe méritante
he qui qui joue depuis des années
ensemble on va voir si ça commence à
payer ou pas c'est un peu compliqué les
début d'année il y a toujours des
petites choses qui vont pas et pour
terminer le 78 sport comme d'habitude
place à votre agenda du weekend et à
deux dates à ne pas rater tout d'abord
du karaté tout le weekend Montini
accueille les championnats de France de
karaté shitoru rendez-vous au complexe
Pierre de Coubertin pour assister au
combat et au kata championnats nationaux
d'ailleurs qui débuteront par un stage
vendredi soir animé par le grand maître
japonais idetoshi nakashi 9e dan de
karaté et il y aura aussi du volleyball
au programme dimanche 26 c'est le derby
de régional une pour le compte de la 8e
journée montinil bretonux reçoit le
leader plaisir Villepreux coup d'envoi à
16h30 toujours à Coubertin c'est la fin
de ce 7 sport merci encore une fois de
l'avoir suivi n'hésitez pas à le
commenter sur les réseaux sociaux et
twit avec le hashag tout attaché le 78
sport d'ici là excellente soirée sur
TVfil à la semaine
prochaine